so
so
foreign
[Music]
please
see
uh
questions
um
is
you
uh
working
please please down thank you thank you
good afternoon before we take questions
i want to make give you a progress
report
to the nation on uh on
where we stand 65 days into office here
on vaccinations and a few other top
priorities for the american people
first on vaccinations on december 8th
i indicated that i hope to get
100 million shots in people's arms
in my first 100 days we met that goal
last week by day 58
42 days ahead of schedule now today i'm
setting the second goal
and that is we will by my 100th day in
office
have administered 200 million shots in
people's arms
that's right 200 million shots in 100
days
uh yeah i know it's ambitious twice our
original goal
but no other country in the world has
even come close
not even close to what we are doing
i believe we can do it and today
we made a historic investment in
reaching the hardest hit
and the most vulnerable communities the
highest-risk communities
as a consequence of the virus by
investing an additional
10 billion dollars in being able to
reach them
i also set a goal before i took office
of getting a
majority of schools in
k through 8 fully open in the first 100
days
now thanks to the enormous amount of
work done by our administration
educators parents local state education
officials and leaders
recent department of education survey
shows that
nearly half of the k-8 schools are open
now full-time
five days a week for in-person learning
not yet a majority
but we're really close and i believe in
the 35 days left to go we'll meet that
goal as well
as of yesterday more than 100 million
payments of one thousand four hundred
dollars
have gone into people's bank accounts
that's real money
in people's pockets bringing relief
instantly almost
and millions more were getting their
money very soon
one final note since we passed the
american rescue plan
we're starting to see new signs of hope
in our economy
since it was passed a majority a
majority of economic forecasters
have significantly increased their
projections
on the economic growth that's going to
take place this year
they're now projecting it will exceed
six percent a six percent growth in gdp
and just this morning we learned the
number of people
filing for weekly unemployment insurance
fell by nearly 100 000 persons
it's the first time in a year the number
has fallen
below the pre-pandemic high
so there are still too many americans
out of work too many families hurting
and i still have a lot of work to do but
i can say
to you the american people help is here
and hope is on the way now i'll be happy
to
take your questions
zeke the associated press
thank you president you mentioned your
progress on combination i'd like to ask
you about some of the other issues
facing your presidency one of the
defining challenges you face in the
coming months
is how to deliver under promise to
americans on issues like immigration
reform
gun control voting rights climate change
all of those right now are facing stiff
united opposition
republicans on capitol hill how far
are you willing to go to achieve those
promises that you made the american
people
well i mean look when uh
i took office i uh
decided that uh it was a fairly basic
simple proposition
and that is i got elected to solve
problems
and the most urgent problem facing the
american people i stated from the outset
was code 19 and the economic
dislocation for millions and millions of
americans
and so that's why i put all my focus in
the beginning
for a lot of problems but all my focus
on dealing
with those particular problems
and the other problems we're talking
about from immigration
to guns and the other things you
mentioned are
long-term problems they've been around a
long time and
what we're going to be able to do god
willing is
now begin one at a time to focus on
those as well
and whether it's immigration or guns or
a number of other problems that face the
country but the fundamental problem
is getting people some peace of mind
so they can go to bed at night and not
stare at the ceiling wondering whether
they lost their health insurance
whether they're going to lose some
family member whether they're going to
be in a position where
they're not going to be they're going to
lose their home because they can't pay
mortgage where the millions of people
are going to get thrown out of their
homes because
of the inability to uh to pay the rent
so we're going to move on these one at a
time
try to do as many simultaneous as we can
but
that's the reason why i focused as i
have
and here's the deal i think my
republican colleagues are going to have
to determine
whether or not we want to work together
or they're decide that the way in which
they want to proceed
is to is to uh just
decide to divide the country continue
the politics of division
but i'm not going to do that i'm just
going to move forward and take these
things as they come
follow up mr president can your
presidency be a success if you can't
make
progress on those four challenges
climate change immigration reform gun
control
well i plan on making progress on all of
them but that's going to be for the
american people to decide
i think you know i i doubt whether maybe
you did maybe others did i
i i thought many of you thought there
was no possibility of my getting
the plan i got passed passed without any
republican votes
pretty big deal got passed
growing the economy people's lives are
changing
so let's see what happens all i know
i've been hired to solve problems
to solve problems not create division
uh okay uh how about
yamiche
thanks so much mr president um you've
said over and over again
that immigrants shouldn't come to this
country right now this isn't the time to
come
that message is not being received
instead the question of you
that got you elected as a moral decent
and it
the reason a lot of immigrants are
coming to country and trusting you with
unaccompanied minors
how do you resolve that tension and how
are you choosing which families can stay
which can can go given that even though
with title 42 there are some families
that are staying
and is there a timeline for when you
won't be seeing these overcrowded
facilities
with run by cpp when it comes to
unaccompanied minors
well look i guess i should be flattered
people are coming because i'm the nice
guy that's the reason why it's happening
that i'm a decent man or whatever's
phrased you know that's why they're
coming because no biden's a good guy
truth of the matter is nothing has
changed
as many people came 28 increase in
children to the border
in my administration 30 in the last year
of in 2019 before the pandemic
in the trump administration it happens
every single solitary year
there is a significant increase
the number of people coming to the
border in the winter months
of january february march
it happens every year in addition to
that there is
a and nobody and by the way
does anybody suggest that there was a 31
increase under trump because he was in
the sky and he was doing
good things at the border that's not the
reason they're coming
the reason they're coming is that it's
the time they can travel with the least
likelihood of dying on the way because
of the heat in the desert
number one number two they're coming
because
of the circumstances in country
in country the way to deal with this
problem
and i started to deal with it back when
i was state senator
i mean vice president putting together a
bipartisan
plan of over 700 million dollars to do
the root causes that people are leaving
what did trump do he eliminated that
funding
he didn't use it he'd do it in addition
to that
what he did he dismantled all the
elements
that exist to deal with what had been a
problem
and has been continued to be a problem
for a long time
he in fact shut down the
uh number of ed's available he did not
fund
hhs to get people to get the children
out of those
those border patrol facilities where
they should not be and not supposed to
be more than
a few days a little while but he
dismantled all of that
that's what we're doing now is we're
attempting to rebuild
rebuild
all of that and so what we're doing now
is attempting to rebuild
rebuild the system that can accommodate
the what is happening today and i'd love
to think it's because i'm a nice guy but
it's not it's because of what's happened
every year let me say one other thing on
this if you take a look
at the number the vast
majority the overwhelming majority of
people
coming to the border crossing are being
sent back
or being sent back thousands
tens of thousands of people who are
who are over 18 years of age and single
people one at a time coming have been
sent
back sent home we're sending back the
vast majority of the families that are
coming
we're trying to work out now with mexico
willingness to take
more of those families back but we
that that's what's happening they're not
getting across the border and those who
are coming across the border who are
unaccompanied children
were moving rapidly to try to put in
place what was dismantled
as i said for example of all the
children are coming across the border
over 70 percent are either 16 or 17
years old
we're not talking about people ripping
babies from mother's arms or little
three-year-olds standing on the border
less than i think it's one and a half
percent fall
in the category of the very young so
what we're doing
is we're providing for the space again
to be able to get these kids out of the
border patrol facilities which no
child no one should be in any longer
than 72 hours and today
i went to for example i lose all the
resources available to me
went to the defense department and and
this the secretary of defense has just
made available
fort bliss 5 000 beds
immediately available 5 000 beds in the
texas border
so we're building back up the capacity
that should have been maintained and
built upon
that trump dismantled it's going to take
time
and the other thing we're doing i might
add am i giving you two
answer because if you don't want the
detail
no no but i mean i i don't know how much
detail you want about immigration
maybe i'll stop there in new york my
follow-up question
is um one if you could talk a little bit
about which families why they're being
allowed to say
what the families that are being allowed
to stay why they're being allowed in
addition to that
when it comes to the filibuster which is
what zeke was asking about
there's immigration is a big issue of
course when it related to the filibuster
but there's also
republicans who are passing bill after
bill
trying to restrict voting rights chuck
schumer is calling it
an existential threat to democracy why
not back
a filibuster rule that at least gets
around issues including voting rights or
immigration
jim cliver someone of course you know
very well
um has backed the idea of a filibuster
rule when it comes to civil rights and
voting rights
well look um i'm going to deal with all
problems the question is the priorities
as they come and land on my plate let's
go to the first question you asked
the first of the second questions you
asked and that is
what about dealing with families why are
not
some not going back because mexico
is refusing to take them back
they're saying they won't take them back
not all of them we're in negotiations
with the president of mexico i think
we're going to see that change
they should all be going back all be
going back
the only people were not going to let
sitting there on the other side of the
rio grande by themselves with no help
are children and what we're doing there
and it's important point to understand i
know you understand i don't mean to say
it that way
important point to focus on the vast
majority of people
under the age of 18 come to the united
states come
with a telephone number on the on a
wristband
or come with a telephone number in their
pocket in the united states
a mother a father a close relative a
grandmom or grandpa
what was happening before is this taking
literally
weeks and weeks and maybe even months
before anybody pick up the phone and
call
to see if there really was someone there
well
we've set up a system now where within
24 hours there's a phone call made
as that person that child crosses the
border
and then a verification system being put
in places
as of today to determine quickly whether
or not
that is a trafficker being called or
that is actually
a mom a dad and or a close relative
they're establishing that right off the
bat if it in fact
is mom or dad dad says to take the
extreme case i got a birth certificate
and guess what we're getting that kid
directly to
that parent immediately and so
that's going to reduce significantly
there's two ways to reduce
child populations in circumstances that
are not acceptable
like being held at a border patrol
station
one is to get them to the place where
they
have a relative and set a date as to
when a hearing can be held
second way to do it is put them in a a
health and human services facility
that we're occupying now both licensed
beds around the country
that exist as well as for example
federal resources like fort bliss to get
them
safely in a place where they can be
taken care of
while their fate is determined
filibuster fulfill the filibuster um you
know
with regard to the filibuster i believe
we should go back to a position in the
filibuster that existed just when i came
to the united states senate 120 years
ago
and that is that it used to be required
for the filibuster
and i had a card on this i was going to
give you the statistics but you probably
know them
that it used to be that uh
that well from between 1917 and 1971 the
filibuster existed
there were a total of 58 motions
to break a filibuster that whole time
last year alone there were five
times that many so it's being abused in
a gigantic way
and for example it used to be you had to
stand there
and talk and talk and talk and talk
until you collapsed
and guess what people got tired of
talking and tired of collapsing
filibusters broke down and were able to
break the filibuster get a quorum and
vote
so i strongly support moving in that
direction in addition to
having an open mind about dealing with
certain things that are
are just elemental to the functioning of
our democracy
like the root to vote like the basic
right to vote we've amended the
filibuster in the past
but here's the deal as you observed i'm
a fairly practical guy
i want to get things done i want to get
them
done consistent with what we promised
the american people
and in order to do that in a 50-50
senate
we've got to get the place where i get
50 votes
so that the vice president united states
can break the tie or i get 51 votes
without her
so i'm going to say something outrageous
i have never been particularly poor at
calculating how to get things done
in the united states senate so the best
way to get something done
if you if you hold near and dear to you
that you uh
like to be able to anyway
we're gonna get a lot done and if we
have to if there's complete
lockdown and chaos as a consequence of
the filibuster then
we'll have to go beyond what i'm talking
about
okay um hang on
uh sorry
oh say miss kim
thank you mr president um to follow up
on the filibuster
so do you believe it should take 60
votes to end a filibuster on legislation
or 51.
if we could end it with 51 we would have
no problem
you're going to have to the existing
rule
it's going to be hard to get a
parliamentary ruling that allows
50 votes to end the filibuster the
existence of a filibuster
but
it's not my expertise and what the
parliamentary rules and how to get
there are but our preoccupation with the
filibuster is totally legitimate
but in the meantime we've got a lot we
can do while we're talking about what
we're gonna do
about the filibuster um
let me get here okay uh
um cecilia vega
i'd like to circle back to immigration
please uh
you just listed the reasons that people
are coming uh
talking about in-country problems saying
that it happens every year you
blame the last administration sir i just
got back last night from a reporting
trip to the border
where i met nine-year-old jose who
walked here
from honduras by himself along with
another little boy he had that phone
number on him
and we were able to call his family his
mother
says that she sent her son to this
country because she believes
that you are not deporting unaccompanied
minors like her son that's why she sent
him a loan from honduras
so sir you blamed the last
administration but is your messaging in
saying that these children are
will be allowed to stay in this country
and work their way through this process
encouraging families like joe says to
come
look
the idea that i'm gonna say
which i would never do if an
unaccompanied child ends up at the
border we're just going to let him
starve to death and stay in the other
side
no previous administration is dead
either except trump
i'm not going to do it i'm not going to
do it
that's why i've asked the vice president
united states yesterday
to be the lead person on dealing with
focusing on the fundamental reasons why
people leave honduras guatemala
el salvador in the first place it's
because of
earthquakes floods it's because of
lack of food it's because of gang
violence is because of a
whole range of things that when i was
vice president had the same obligation
to deal with unaccompanied children
i was able to get it slowed up
significantly by working with the head
of state of those
communities to do things like in one of
the major cities
the reason people were leaving is they
couldn't walk the street because they
were getting
their kids were getting beat up or shot
or gang violence
well what i was able to do is not give
money to
the head of state because so many are
corrupt but i was able to say okay you
need lightning in the streets to change
things
i'll put the lighting in we got a
contractor
we got the type of lighting we paid
directly the contract did not go through
the government
and violent crime significantly was
reduced in that city
fewer people sought to leave this
hurricane
occurred the two hurricanes instead of
us going down and helping
in a major way so that people would not
have
reason to want to leave in the first
place because they didn't have housing
or water
or sustenance we did nothing
we're going to do a lot in our
administration
we're going to be spending that 700 plus
million dollars a year
to change the life and circumstances of
why people leave in the first place
that mother did not with on the kitchen
table
and said you know i got a great idea why
i'm going to make sure my son get taken
care of
is i'm going to put him how old was he
or she
nine i also met a ten-year-old a a
nine-year-old i'm gonna send him on a
thousand-mile journey across the desert
and up to the united states
because i know joe biden's a nice guy
and he'll take care of him what a
desperate act
to have to take circumstances must be
horrible
so we can do something about that that's
what the vice president's going to be
doing
what i did when president obama asked me
to come and deal i was in
i was in uh turkey at the time he said
you got to come home and take care of
this
so we put together a plan and it had an
impact
and so the question here is whether how
we go ahead and do this what we do
there's no easy answer
quick follow if i may do you want to see
these unaccompanied minors
staying in this country or should they
be deported eventually
well the judgment has to be made whether
or not and
in this young man's case he has the mom
at home
there's a overwhelming reason why he'd
be putting the plane and flown back to
his mom
follow sir you mentioned circumstances
that must be horrific
the customs and border protection
facility in donna texas i was there
is at 1 56 capacity
right now with mostly unaccompanied
minor there are kids that are sleeping
on floors
they are packed into these pods i've
spoken to lawyers
who say that they some of these children
have not seen the sun in days
what's your reaction what is your
reaction to these images that have come
out from that particular facility
is what's happening inside acceptable to
you
and when it's going to be fixed is
that's a serious question right
is it acceptable to me come on that's
why
we're going to be moving a thousand of
those kids out quickly
that's why i got fort bliss opened up
that's why i've been working from the
moment
this started to happen to try to find
additional access
for children to be able to safely not
just children but particularly children
to be able to safely be housed while we
follow through on the rest of what's
happening
that is totally unacceptable
um ben
thank you mr president i wanted to ask
you about afghanistan
you face a may first deadline for the
withdrawal
of u.s troops from that country
as a candidate in foreign affairs you
wrote
that it is past time to end these
forever wars
can you commit to the american people
that by may 2nd
the u.s will no longer have forces
in afghanistan the answer is that
it's going to be hard to meet the may 1
deadline
it's in terms of tactical reasons hard
to get
those troops out so what we've been
doing what i've been doing
and what secretary blinken has been
doing
has been we've been meeting with our
allies
those other nations that have nato
allies who have
troops in afghanistan as well
and uh and if we leave we're going to do
so in a safe
and orderly way uh we're in consultation
i said with our allies and partners
and how to proceed and secretary blink
is meeting in brussels this week with
our nato
allies particularly those who have
horses there
and general austin is just met with
kyani and i'm waiting for the briefing
on that
he's the the the leader
in afghanistan and kabul and
there's a un-led process that's
beginning
shortly on how to mechanically get
people
how to end this war but it is not my
intention
to stay there for a long time but the
question is
how and in what circumstances do we meet
that agreement that was made by
president trump to
leave under a deal that looks like it's
not being able to be worked out to begin
with
how how's that done but we are not
staying a long time
do you think it's possible that we will
leave the question is
when we leave sorry do you believe
though it's possible we could have
troops there
next year i
i can't picture that being the case
okay uh kristen
thank you very much mr president given
the conditions that were just laid
at migrant facilities at the us border
will you commit to allowing journalists
to have
access to the facilities that are
overcrowded moving forward
i will commit when my plan very shortly
is underway to let you have access to
not just them but other facilities as
well
people have access to the facilities
we've obviously
been allowed to be inside one but we
haven't seen
the facilities in which children are
packed
together to really give the american
people a chance to see that will you
commit to transparency on this
i will commit to transparency and as
soon as i am in a position to be able to
implement
what we're doing right now and one of
the reasons i haven't gone down
i've all my my chief folks have gone
down is i don't want to become
the issue i don't want to be you know
bringing
all the secret service and everybody
with me to get in the way
so this is being set up and you'll have
full access to everything once we get
this
moving just to be clear how soon will
that be mr president
i don't know to be clear
responsibility for everything that's
happening at the border now i hear you
talking a lot about the past
administration
you decided to roll back some of those
policies did you move
too quickly roll back what i'm sorry
policies
did you move too quickly to roll back
some of the executive orders of your
predecessor first of all
all the policies are underway were not
helping at all
did not slow up the amount of
immigration and there's many people
coming
and rolling back the policies of
separating children from their
from their mothers make no apology for
that rolling back the policies have
remained in mexico sitting on the edge
of the rio grande and the muddy
circumstance with not enough to eat but
i make no apologies for that
i make no apologies for ending programs
that did not exist
before trump became president
that have an incredibly negative impact
on
the law international law
as well as on human dignity and so i
make no apologies for that
i want to ask you about mr president
overnight
we learned that north korea tested
two ballistic missiles what if
any actions will you take and what is
your red line on north korea
let me say that number one
u.n resolution 1718 was
violated by those particular missiles
that were tested
number one we're consulting with our
allies
and partners and uh
there will be uh responses if they
choose to escalate
um we will respond accordingly
but i'm also prepared
for some form of diplomacy um
but it has to be conditioned upon
the end of denuclearization
so uh um
that's what we're doing right now
consulting with our allies just
very quickly you only got another hour
okay diplomacy
can you define what you mean and former
president obama
warned the incoming president trump
that north korea was the top foreign
policy issue that he was watching
is that how you assess the crisis in
north korea yes
okay hang on a second here kristen uh
nancy cbs
thank you very much mr president i want
to go back to voting rights
and as mentioned republican legislatures
across the country are working to pass
bills that would restrict voting
particularly democrats fear
impacting minority voters and young
voters the very people who helped to get
you
elected in november are you worried
that if you don't manage to pass
voting rights legislation that your
party is going to lose seats and
possibly lose control
of the house and the senate in 2022
what i'm worried about is how unamerican
this whole initiative is it's sick
it's sick exciting in some states that
you cannot
bring water to people standing in line
waiting to vote deciding that you're
going to
end voting at five o'clock when working
people are just
getting off work deciding that
there will be no absentee ballots under
the most
rigid circumstances it's all designed
and i'm going to spend my time
doing three things one trying to figure
out how to
pass the legislation passed by the house
number one number two educating the
american public
the republican voters i know
find this despicable republican voters
the folks out in the outside this white
house
i'm not talking about the le the elected
officials
i'm talking about voters voters
and so i'm convinced that we'll be able
to stop this because it is the most
pernicious thing
this makes jim crow look like jim eagle
i mean this is gigantic what they're
trying to do
and it cannot be sustained and do
everything on my power along with my
friends in the house and the senate to
keep that from
becoming the law is there anything else
you can do about it besides passing
legislation
the answer is yes but i'm not going to
lay out a strategy
in front of the whole world in you now
and
then on a related note have you decided
whether you are going to run for
re-election
in 2024 you haven't set up a re-election
campaign yet as your predecessor had by
this time
my friend said you need to need to
my predecessor oh god i miss him
have you have you oh and answer is yes
my plan is to run for re-election that's
my expectation
and then on on one other note on
bipartisanship your old friend mitch
mcconnell
says you have only spoken to each other
once
since you took office and that you have
moved far
left since taking office do you see it
the same way he does
have you rejected bipartisanship no i
haven't at all
a meeting when's the last time a
president invited
the opposite party down at least a half
a dozen times to talk about issues
everything from
how we work i'm we're working with a
group of 20
members of the senate right now in-house
on how we
reestablish our ability to make computer
chips
how we get ahead of the game how we can
work together we're working together on
a bunch of things but look
i know mitch well mitch knows me well i
would expect mitch to say exactly what
he said
but this is a matter of making sure that
i would like republican
elected republican support but what i
know i have now is that i have
electoral support from republican voters
republican voters agree with what i'm
doing
and so unless mitch says the last thing
i did this
last piece of legislation is so far left
well then he ought to take a look at his
party
over 50 percent of them must be over
that edge as well
because they support what i did uh
okay um where am i here
let me see caitlin
thank you very much mr president i have
a question for you but first i'd like to
follow up on
a question from yamiche and that's on
the that counts as a question but go
ahead okay i'll make it quick
no no you can't uh regarding the
filibuster
at john lewis's funeral president barack
obama said he believed the filibuster
was
a relic of the jim crow era do you agree
yes if not why not abolish it if it's a
relic of the juco era
successful electoral politics is the art
of possible
let's figure out how we can get this
done
and move the direction significantly
changing the abuse of even the
filibuster rule
first it's been abused from the time it
came into being
by an extreme way in the last
20 years let's deal with the abuse first
it sounds like you're moving closer to
eliminating the filibuster is that
correct
i answered your question you also just
made some news by saying that you are
going to run for re-election
you said that is my expectation so is
that a yes that you are running for
re-election
okay i i don't know where you guys come
from man i've never been able to travel
i'm a great
respecter of faith i've never been able
to plan four and a half three and a half
years ahead for certain
and if you do if you do run will vice
president harris be on your ticket
i would fully expect that to be the case
she's doing a great job she's a great
partner
she's a great partner and do you believe
you'll be running against former
president trump
oh come on i don't even think about i
don't have i have no idea
i have no idea there'll be a republican
party do you
i know you don't have to answer my
question i mean oh do you i mean look
this is
the way i view things i become a great
respecter of fate in my life
i set a goal of those that's in front of
me to get things done
for the people i care most about which
the hard-working decent american people
have been really
having stuck to them i want to change
the paradigm
i want to change the paradigm we start
to reward
work not just wealth i want to change
the paradigm if you notice
didn't you find it kind of interesting
that my republican friends were worried
about
that the cost and the taxes that had to
be
had if there is any tax to be had as
they talk about it
and dealing with the the that we just
passed
which puts money in people's pockets
ordinary people
do you hear them complain when they
passed close to two trillion dollar
trump tax cut
83 percent going to the top one percent
do you hear them talk about that at all
i love the fact that they found
this whole idea of concern about
the federal budget it's kind of amazing
when the federal budget is saving
people's lives
they don't think it's such a good idea
when the federal budget is feathering
the nest of the wealthiest americans
90 of the fortune 500 companies making
billions of dollars not paying a cent in
taxes
reducing taxes to the point that
people who are making you know if your
husband and wife
school teacher and a cop you're paying
at a higher rate than the average person
making a
billion dollars a year is
something wrong their newfound concern
i'm concerned look
i meant what i said when i ran and a lot
of you still think i'm wrong and i
respect that so i'm running for three
reasons
to restore the soul dignity honor
honesty transparency to the american
political system two
to rebuild the backbone of this country
the middle class
hardworking people and people struggling
in the middle class they
built america and unions built them
the third reason i said i was running
was to unite the country
and generically speaking all of you said
no you can't do that
well i've not been able to unite the
congress but i've been uniting the
country
based on the polling data
we have to come together we have to
so from my perspective you know it's uh
to me it's about just
you know getting out there putting one
foot in front of the other and just
trying to make things better for people
just hard working people people get up
every morning and just want to figure
out
how to put food in the table for their
kids to be able to have a little bit of
breathing room
being able to have make sure that they
go to bed not starting to sit like my
dad did wonder whether
since he didn't have health insurance
what happens if mom gets sick or he got
sick
these are basic things basic things
and i'm of the view that the vast
majority of people
including registered republicans by and
large
share that that that same that same view
that same sense of
what is uh you know what's appropriate
justin justin sink bloomberg
uh thanks mr president i wanted to ask
about your relationship with china now
that you've been on
office for a couple months there's
obviously the meeting in alaska that
was a little theatrical and there's the
continued human rights pieces so today
i'm wondering
are you more likely you were when you
came into office to maintain
tariffs on china are you considering
banning imports
of forced labor products and
would you consider cutting off u.s
investment or chinese access to
uh international payment systems well
look
uh
they're each specifically legitimate
questions
but they only touch
a smidgen of what the relationship with
china really is about
i've known xi jinping for a long time
allegedly by the time i left office's
vice president i'd spent more time with
xi jinping than any world leader had
because president obama
and the chinese president who decided we
should get to know one another
since it was inappropriate for the
president united states to spend time
with the vice president of another
country
but it was obvious he was going to
become the new leader of china
so i spent hours upon hours with him
along with an interpreter my interpreter
and his
going into great detail is very very
straightforward
doesn't have a democratic with a small d
bone in his body
but he's a smart smart guy he's one of
the guys
like putin who thinks that autocracy is
the wave of the future democracy can't
function in an ever
in ever complex world so
when i was elected and he called to
congratulate me
i think to the surprise of the china
experts who were
his people on the call as well as mine
listening
we had a two-hour conversation
for two hours and
we made several things clear to one
another
i made it clear to him again what i've
told them in person on several occasions
that we're not looking for confrontation
although we know there will be steep
steep competition
two that will have strong competition
but will insist that china play by the
international rules
fair competition fair practice is fair
trade
thirdly in order to compete effectively
i indicated
that we're going to deal with china
effectively and we're going to need
three things to do that
telling our people first we're going to
invest in american workers in american
science
i said that all through the campaign i
say it again and we're
i'm setting up my administration to be
able to do that which is that
you know back in the 60s we used to
invest a little over two percent of our
entire
entire gdp in pure research an
investment in
science today it's 0.7 percent
i'm going to change that
the future lies in who can in fact
own the future as it relates to
technology quantum computing a whole
range of things
including the medical fields and so
what i'm going to do is make sure we
invest
closer to two percent one of the reasons
why
i've set up the the p
ab the president's board with science
and sunlight again
is uh we're gonna invest in medical
research
cancer alzheimer's diabetes the things
industries of the future artificial
intelligence quantum computing
biotech and we're going to make real
investments
china is out investing us by a long shot
because their plan is to own that future
the third the second thing we're going
to do is we're going to re-establish our
alliances and i've been very clear with
it
it's not the anti-chinese and we've
talked about it
i want to make sure that for example
later today after this matter of fact
shortly after this um which is fine
i'm going closer now all right i'm happy
go go longer but one of the things that
i'm going to be doing
i'm going to be speaking with 27 heads
of state in europe
and very shortly i think in the next
hour so i know the exact time
and uh earlier this month and apparently
got the chinese attention that's not why
i did it
i met with our allies and how we're
going to hold china accountable in the
region
australia india japan the united states
the so-called quad
because we have to have
democracies working together
before too long i'm going to have i'm
going to invite
an alliance of democracies to come here
to discuss the future
and so we're going to make it clear that
in order to deal with these things
we are going to hold china accountable
to follow the rules
follow the rules whether it relates to
the
south china sea the north china sea or
the agreement made on taiwan or a whole
range of other things
and the third thing and the thing that i
i admire about dealing with she is he
understands he makes
no no pretense about not understanding
what i'm saying anymore i knew him
i pointed out to him no leader can be
sustained in his position or her
position
unless they represent the values of the
country and i said as
and uh mr president as i've told you
before
americans value the notion of freedom
america values human rights we don't
always live up to our expectations but
there's a value system
we are founded on that principle
and as long as you and your country
continues to so blatantly
violate human rights we are going to
continue
in an unrelenting way call to the
attention of the world
and make it clear make it clear what's
happening
and he understood that i made it clear
that no american president
at least one did but no american
president ever
backed down from speaking out of what's
happened to the uyghurs
what's happening in hong kong what's
happening in
in in country that's who we are
the moment a president walked away from
that the last one did
is the moment we begin to lose our
legitimacy around the world
which we are so i see
stiff competition with china
china has an overall goal and i don't
criticize them for the goal
but they have an overall goal to become
the leading country in the world
the wealthiest country in the world and
the most powerful country in the world
that's not going to happen on my watch
because united states is going to
continue to grow
and expand sorry just to follow up on
the meeting of democracies is that what
you
expect in a multilateral way to make
these decisions about
uh sanctions or no that's not my
decision that's where i make sure we're
all on the same page
on the same page look i predict to you
your children or grandchildren are going
to be doing their
doctoral thesis on issue of
who succeeded autocracy or democracy
because that is what is at stake not
just in china
look around the world we're in the midst
of a fourth industrial revolution
of enormous consequence will there be
middle class
how will people adjust to these
significant
changes in science and technology
the environment how will they do that
and our democracy is equipped because
all the people get to speak
to compete it is clear
absolutely clear and most of the
scholars i dealt with at penn
agree with me around the country
that this is a battle between the
utility of democracies in the 21st
century
and autocracies if you notice you don't
have
russia talking about communism anymore
it's about an autocracy
demand decisions made by
a leader of a country that's what's at
stake here we got to prove democracy
works
mr president sorry i know you have
another chance to address
the tragedies in georgia and colorado
you had said to stay tuned for actions
that you might take on gun control
wondering if you've made a decision
either about sending the
manufacturer liability bill that you
promised on day one to capitol hill
or executive actions like going after
ghost guns
or giving money to cities and states to
battle gun control
all the above it's a matter of timing
as you've all observed
successful presidents better than me
have been successful in large part
because they know how to time what
they're doing
order it deciding priorities
what need to be done the next major
initiative is
and i'll be noticing it friday in
pittsburgh in detail
is to build
the infrastructure both physical and
technological infrastructure this
country
so that we can compete and create
significant numbers
of really good paying jobs
really good paying jobs
and some of you have been around long
enough to know
that used to be a great republican goal
initiative
i still think the majority of the
american people
don't like the fact that we are now
ranked what 85th in the world and
infrastructure i mean
look the future rests on whether or not
we have
the best airports that can accommodate
air travel ports that you can get out of
quickly
so businesses decide some of you when
you're if you're ever local reporters
and you found your governor or mayor
trying to attract business to your
community what's the first thing the
business
asked what's the closest access
access to an interstate highway how far
am i from
freight rail is the water
is the water available is enough water
available for me to conduct my business
all the things that relate to
infrastructure we have
somewhere i i asked the staff to write
it down for me and they did not for this
but
for a longer discussion we have
somewhere
uh in terms of infrastructure
we have we ranked 13th globally in
infrastructure
china is investing three times more in
infrastructure than the united states is
bridges more than one-third of our
bridges 231 000 of them
need repairs some are physical safety
risks
or preservation work one in five miles
of our highways and major roads are in
poor condition
that's 186 000 miles of highway
aviation 20 of all flights
20 of all flights weren't on time
resulting in 1.5 million hours
lost in production 6
to 10 million homes in america still
have
lead pipes servicing their water lines
we have over a hundred thousand
wellheads that are not
capped leaky methane
what are we doing and by the way
we can put as many pipe fritters
and miners on us to work capping those
wells
at the same price that they were charged
to dig those wells
so i i just find it um
frustrating frustrating talk about
last point i'll make in the
infrastructure and i apologize for
spending more time on it but is that
if you think about it
um it's the place
where we will be able to significantly
increase american productivity
at the same time providing
really good jobs for people
but we can't build back to what they
used to be
we have to build the environments our
global warming's already done
significant damage
the roads that used to be
[Music]
above the water level
didn't have to worry about where the
drainage was
now you got to rebuild them three feet
higher because it's not going to go back
to what it was before only get worse
unless we stop it there's so
much we can do look at all the schools
in america most of you live in the
washington area
now but in your hometowns i don't know
where you're all from
how many schools where the kids can't
drink the water out of the fountain
how many schools are still in a position
where there's asbestos
how many schools in america we're
sending our kids to
don't have adequate ventilation
how many homes buildings
office complexes are wasting
billions of barrels of oil over time
because they can't hold in
the heat or the air conditioning
because this leaks through the windows
that are so porous
and the connections it's amazing
so there's so much we can do that's good
stuff
makes people healthier and creates good
jobs and i think that
i got one more question here and janet
uh from univision thank you mr president
we too have been reporting at the border
and just like cecilia we run into a pair
of siblings who came in on monday
were detained by cbp had the phone
number for their mother who lives in the
u.s
we have contacted the mother that's the
only way they know
her kids are here because cbp today
thursday has not contacted that mother
so when can we expect your promise of
things getting better
with contacting and experiencing well
they're already getting better but
they're going to get
real i got a whole hell of a lot better
real quick we're going to hear some
people leaving
okay we can get this done we're going to
get it done i had a long meeting with
the entire
team and several cabinet level officers
the other night
we're going to be moving within the next
within the next week over 100 000 i mean
a thousand people out of uh
the border patrol into safe secure
beds and facilities we're gonna
significantly ramp up we're already out
there contacting
everyone from getting some of the
employees at hhs
there's a lot of them doing other things
and move them into making those calls
we're in the process of rearranging and
providing for the personnel
needed to get that done but i admire the
fact that you
die or you can call it yourself it's
real
and that has to happen though as you
well know has to happen we have to be
some certitude
that this is the actually mom dad or
whomever
and there's ways to do that there's to
do a little bit like
determining whether or not you got the
right
code for your credit card uh you know
what what was your dog's name kind of
thing i'm being a bit facetious but not
really
and also seeking harder data from dna
to to birth certificates which takes
longer
so i want to do this as as
quickly as humanly possible and as
safely as possible
well not treating the root cause it
causes in latin america doesn't change
things overnight
how do you realistically and physically
keep these families from
coming to the us when things will not
get better
in their countries right away well
i i can't guarantee that but i know
you know that old thing the journey of a
thousand miles starts with the first
step
you know as i do you cover it
you have serious it's not like
somebody's sitting on a
hand you table in guatemala i mean in in
somewhere in mexico or
in guadalupe saying i got a great idea
let's sell everything we have give it to
a coyote
have them take our kids across the
border into the desert where they don't
speak the language
won't that be fun let's go
that's not how it happens people don't
want to leave
when my great-grandfather got in a
coffin ship in the irish sea
expectation wasn't was he was going to
live long enough
on that ship to get to the united states
of america but they left because of what
brits had been doing
they were in real real trouble they
didn't want to leave
but they had no choice so you've got
we can't i can't guarantee we're going
to solve everything
but i can guarantee we can make
everything better
we can make it better we can change the
lives of so many people and the other
thing i want to point out to you
and i hope you point out i realize
it's much more heart wrenching and it is
to deal with a five and six and
seven-year-old
but you went down there and you saw the
vast majority of these
children 70 percent are 16 years old 17
years old and mostly males
that make it doesn't make it good better
and different but the idea
that we have tens of thousands of kids
in these god-awful facilities that are
really little babies
crying all night there's some that's
true that's what we gotta add and
yesterday i asked my team
both the director of the two agencies as
well as others
i asked them what would they in fact and
i asked their opinion because they're
the experts but i said
focus on the most vulnerable immediately
but there's no reason why in the next
month as people cross the border phone
call
be made in the first 48 hours and begin
i may ask one last question have you had
any talks with
senate republicans who are threatening
this administration was not considering
the immigration legislation that was
passed in the house until the situation
at the border
has been resolved no because i know they
have to posture for a while
they would have got to get out of their
system
this is a
but i i'm ready to work with any
republican
who wants to help solve the problem
and make make the situation better but
folks
i'm going thank you very very much i
appreciate it thank you
[Music]
you